You saw in the simple lexer that we wrote
that tokens come, not just with a type of token in their value,
but also their line number and column number.
That sort of information is very handy
to keep track of for users.
At some point, you may have written an incorrect Python program--nah.
I've only written about a million of them.
And it's really nice when the interpreter tells you
which line the mistake is on.
Unfortunately, the lexer won't do this for us--entirely automatically.
It will keep track of columns,
but it won't keep track of lines--
unless we do some work.
Here's an example of a rule
that matches new lines.
You may not have seen this before,
but we've already seen how the backslash can be used
to Escape special characters, like the quote.
And this basically just means: quote.
However, when paired with something else,
the backslash often has a special meaning.
\ N is the string equivalent of pressing the Return
or Enter key on your keyboard, and we call this the "newline" key.
It advances your Editor, by 1 line.
So this rule--t_newline--
matches a new line that appears.
And when we see it,
we take the token and increment its line number by 1,
and then we pass over the new line, as if it were Whitespace.
Here you can see that I've added
the newline rule,
just as I described on the previous slide,
to our old lexer from before.
Let's go all the way to the bottom,
and now I'm going to make my Web page
much more complicated.
And here, I'm using triple-quoted strings,
showing line1 on the first line
and line2 on the second.
Unfortunately, the output shows
Line1, followed by the new line.
I'm going to have to go up here
and remove newline from the list of things
that it's possible to have in a Word--just like we had to remove space.
And now we see that Line1 starts on LIne1
and Line2 starts on Line2,
and it's the seventh character from the beginning of the file.
Zero, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 is the newline,
6 is the space, 7 is the capital L. All right.